so with that I am going to turn it off
to our first keynote speaker Chris Clark
she also works at lincoln laboratory
with me but in a completely different
fields she's going to talk about space
cameras and so as Kristen said I'm also
a Kristin but short for I go by chris i
work at lincoln laboratory and i want to
say that this is an amazing program so
first how many of you have ever done a
program like this like an engineering
kind of thing for 4 girls come on way up
I can't see that well okay cool now how
many of you are freshmen sophomores
juniors seniors all right no seniors
they're all busy doing college
application all right so let's get
started so today I'm going to talk a
little bit about me just because we're
kind of looking at what makes an
engineer right they look there it can be
all over the map so there's no one key
picture what an engineer looks like or
what a scientist looks like then we'll
go into a little bit about just really
basic stuff like what is a camera what
are the key components of the camera and
then what can cameras do and then
specifically I'm going to tell you about
the program i'm currently working on it
is a space camera looking for exoplanets
so i'll tell you a little bit about the
specifics of that and i have some kind
of cool animations that they did for me
to show you the orbit and all that sort
of stuff so stop me raise your hand
questions you know you don't have to
wait till the end or anything so just
speak up raise your hand get my
attention so how I got here so you guys
all know this is Massachusetts right I
did not stray very far i was born in
worcester in the center of the state i
moved to billerica mass when i was too
with my family I went to billerica
memorial high school then I went to MIT
for undergraduate than to Tufts for
graduate school so it's kind of this
circle I never went more than 50 miles
from home and ended up at lincoln
laboratory had been there for the last
12 years working on space-based optical
systems so I have three brothers two
morrow so techie geeks one's a lawyer so
he's kind of the amen
out but the only time really that I left
the country was to be an exchange
student for a year in high school and
other than that stayed very close to
home so there's tons of opportunities
right in your own backyard for being an
engineer alright so now I need some
audience participation what is a camera
anyone want to take a stab at just kind
of a general definition of the camera or
even just you're not really sure how to
define it may be just describe what it
does that's a good way to start good
good device that takes photos anybody
want to add to that key piece of
information you can think of that might
improve the definition for if you needed
to describe a camera into somebody light
affects how the photos taken is that
what you said yep yep so light is very
Keef right that's pretty much what we're
trying to collect anybody else want to
add to the definition alright well let's
see this is kind of a generic definition
camera is an optical instrument for
recording or capturing images so if you
look at that definition really there are
two basic components you need two
cameras then you want to want to take a
guess at one or both of them what's the
first thing you have to do and you want
to take a picture all right i'll give
you this one somehow you have to collect
the light right so focus your energy it
can be visible light we'll talk a little
bit more about other types of energy but
once you have that light where you want
it what's the next step it's there but
what do you have to do to get a picture
exactly so you need a detector right so
basically two compliments you want to
get the light for whatever you're trying
to image to a particular place and then
you need some sort of device old-school
if you're old school like we've seen
film cameras before you took some of
those apart so film was the detector now
it's much more the digital age right you
get ccds and all sorts of digital image
or so so those are basically the two
things that you have to do for a camera
and then
they're sky's limit there are so many
different types that you can do so I
thought I'd start really simply is that
has anyone ever heard of a pinhole
camera anyone ever built a pinhole
camera alright so what's the basic
premise do you remember what the ideas
behind a pinhole camera yep so you have
this if I can get my little pointer
thingy to work tiny tiny hole in a dark
box so there's not even a lens in this
camera that but that tiny tiny tiny hole
is the first half of what you need for
cameras something to collect the light
now the problem with a pinhole camera
the tiny tiny hole can't collect much
light but it does limit very
specifically that light from a
particular point and what you're looking
at can only get to a very specific point
on the inside of the box and so
basically that's your limiting light
collection and the back surface of the
box is your image plane now you can't
really capture it because it's just the
back of a box but you can look at it and
it's there if you want to see it so very
very primitive right so if we get into
some things that you guys see every day
and you probably don't really think a
whole lot about how they work but who
would a guest how many components are in
that little tiny phone camera that's a
lot of stuff right there's like six
lenses before you even get to your
detector image so lots of lenses are
used and we won't talk specifically
about lens design but basically the
fancier cameras have gotten you've
noticed like iphone cameras always tell
you oh now we have you know that our
image quality is improved from my phone
for two iphone 6 by whatever percent
it's all about how well you can correct
the light that you're trying to collect
and get it in the spot where you want it
to be and that takes more and more
lenses so that gets more sophisticated
now I like and then you have your
software for image processing right so
you can play around like when you post
them and I'm Way too old for this but
Instagram and Twitter right you can do
like color filters and make it look kind
of different that's all in the image
processing like you guys will get to do
now I like the eye as an example because
you've been using this camera since you
were born and pretty much you have a
lens it focuses the light on
the back of your eye which is called the
retina that's your detector and then
your brain processes the information
from the retina so your brain really is
the image processing software and I
don't know if you guys knew this but if
we go back to what do you notice about
the image of the tree and the pinhole
camera it's upside down right when your
eye lens focuses on the back yet now the
image is actually inverted as well your
brain fixes that for you so it's just
kind of a funny thing like you're
looking at it your lens actually focuses
it upside down but your brain knows that
up and down so kind of an interesting
built-in image processing so can you
guys think of any other examples of
cameras that you use kind of every day
or maybe not every day just specific
ones you've heard of for other maybe for
other applications you seen a camera
somewhere else that you go during the
day or hmm let's see
yeah exactly so in your gut you guys are
going to hear about a really cool
medical imaging camera at lunchtime I
think one that detects tumors in
patients so very good example anybody
get another different example of what
cameras are used for yep infrared
cameras what do those do exactly that
brings us to our next portion so when we
talk about lights anyone familiar with
the term electromagnetic spectrum you
know what that meet can you describe it
a little bit exactly right so so light
and other so we refer to light when most
of the time when you say light you think
of visible light right what we can see
but really the electromagnetic spectrum
just defines in a really large range of
basically electromagnetic waves and this
very small region and we kind of define
this by wavelength right how long is the
is the wavelength of the light most of
the stuff we work with is in this very
small spectrum but it branches all the
way out here to radio frequencies where
you know a wavelength is the size of a
building all the way out to like gamma
rays where a wavelength is like atomic
size right so the big reason probably
that we focus so much on visible that's
where our eyes work that's you know
that's where we learned everything from
the ground up of how imaging works
because we didn't have ccds we didn't
have film a long time ago we only had
eyes and what we could see but now there
are cameras available like you said
infrared and I have a little picture
that right take picture your dog so
basically it's a different type of
camera its collecting infrared light
which your eyes cannot see but the
particular lenses that are used to focus
this light our specific materials that
are used to focus infrared wavelengths
and the detector is sensitive to that
range of wavelengths as well so when we
say we need a lens and a detector it's
important to realize that the materials
that go into those are very specific to
whatever part of the spectrum
you're China try to image so there's an
awful lot that goes into it some people
spend their entire career on visible
system some people work entirely in the
infrared their whole company's flare
system is all about forward-looking
infrared right so their whole business
is built on infrared cameras certainly
medical imaging right you got x-rays so
there's tons of fields and they can be
very specific about what range they're
looking at so I throw up some other
examples some of them you guys already
hit on right so here's that little tiny
that's when you mentioned that so a
little tiny camera that you can actually
swallow and people you know they can
image things in your digestive tract
it's a little bit creepy to think about
but it works certainly if you've been to
the airport any time recently Homeland
Security right cameras everywhere does
anybody know there's a specific kind of
software that they can use with cameras
in the airport that can do something
very specific if you're looking for a
particular person oh sorry face
recognition right right so that's part
of the image processing side of things
right there cameras very sophisticated
that are can scan whole crowds and based
on a still image of a particular person
they can try and pick out facial
features by matching the images so it's
it's pretty amazing stuff when you think
about scanning through a crowd of
hundreds of people and being able to
pick out a specific person so traffic
regulation you know that's a little less
exciting but they take a picture of you
if you run a red light certainly I've
worked on oath sir I worked on a bunch
of programs at lincoln laboratory that
are through that work for to look at
various aspects of whether sensing so
anything i worked on one that was made
to detect lightning because lightning
causes forest fires and if you know
where the lightning is going to strike
you can kind of be prepared so very
specific uses and whether sensing and
then of course that brings us to my
favorite space exploration which is what
I'm working on now so now over a broad
reach of examples I'm going to talk
about specifically the one for space
applications and this is the current
program that I'm work
been working on it for about four years
right from the very beginning will
redevelop the first prototype camera and
we've refined it since then so tell you
a bit about that has anyone heard of it
because it actually has its own Facebook
page which is unusual for a lab program
because it's completely unclassified and
it has lots of followers it's the
science community that's looking to use
the data from test is all over the world
like the test science community actually
meets down the road at Harvard and they
have people from all over Europe and
nobody's heard of it okay so I'm not
really surprised but I figure Facebook
you might have happened upon it so
basically the goal for tests is has an
unheard of Kepler here yeah so do you
know what Kepler was looking for yep who
knows what an exoplanet is anybody
exactly sorry yeah it's any plant so
it's pretty large field right because
we're the only nine i still count Pluto
so any other planet that you can think
of is called max a planet so something
outside of our solar system so Kepler
did look for exoplanets and it was kind
of the first one out there to look and
see what we think there's a lot of
exoplanets out there but let's go look
at a specific section of the sky and
make sure before we build lots of other
missions to go look for exoplanets that
that were kind of right and when Kepler
did confirm there's an awful lot of
exoplanets to look for so long came test
Tess's goal is to go up and it's been
two years basically canvassing the
entire sky looking at specific types of
stars sort of red cooler stars to
identify where exoplanets might be and
we do that it's pretty it's very simple
actually if you have a star and you're
having to be looking at it in the
planets transiting is what it's called
when it passes in front of the planet
what do you think happens if you're
looking at a star you see the light from
the star and the planet goes in front
what do you think happens to the light
there's a shadow right so the light is
decreased and that's really the whole
principle behind test is looking for
those little decreases in the light from
the star now it's got some very specific
things you you know you can only see it
if the play
it is kind of orbiting in front of the
star if it's going around this way
you're not going to see that so it's a
small percentage of you know chances to
pick it up but that's how we're going to
do it so I have kind of a cool movie and
see if I can get this started that shows
we have some really good graphics people
at the lab that put this movie together
so this is the general idea of the
planets going around the star and now at
the bottom it'll start to trace out kind
of a light signal so there's the
Starlight and then as the planet passes
in front of it there's a little dip now
what do you notice when the planet
passes behind the star you may notice
anything interesting like when it passes
in front below the dip is pretty that's
pretty obvious but what's the second dip
anybody got any ideas
yep so somehow we're getting a little
more light signal what do you think that
is exactly exactly right so if you think
of the Sun kind of a star is emitting
radiation in all directions we're seeing
the stuff coming toward us right but as
the planet passes behind the star some
of the light that would be going kind of
backwards gets reflected forwards and
then you get this kind of increase in
your light curve so this is called the
characteristic light curve so if there
were no planet it would just be pretty
much a constant line and what Tess is
doing is looking for these little blips
and they called periodic because it
happens kind of you know get everyone
know what periodic means and the problem
is depending on what star you're looking
at if it's a small planet what do you
think happens to this if the planet gets
bigger anybody the dip gets deeper right
now we're trying to look for earth-like
planets and if you think of Earth
compared to other planets in our solar
system what what size are we like
compared to Jupiter where small right so
Jupiter's easy to find because it
reflects a lot of light it blocks a lot
of light but the smaller you get an
earth is relatively small the smaller
that dip is so Tess really needs to
detect it's about 1% variation in this
very bright signal from a star so that's
the challenge for tests just to show you
a little bit about where test is
orbiting and there's there's a movie so
I won't spend too long in here but
basically here's earth test goes out
really far like 60 earth radius far like
beyond the moon so they call this highly
elliptical and that's for a lot of
different reasons that primarily it's a
very thermally stable orbit so the
temperature stays the same that's one of
many variables that go into designing
space cameras you have to be aware of
the environment that your camera is
going to live in Mike so you could you
design a camera that works in your
laboratory at like 20 degrees Celsius or
70 you know Fahrenheit now you try and
send it into space where it's minus a
might not work out so well so some of
the important considerations and what
test does is it has two orbits per month
that it stares at a very particular
section of the sky and we have four
cameras align so we get a very wide
field of view so we kind of go like this
right there's four cameras and it's
almost almost 100 degrees and its tears
it a section of the sky and then after
month it moves and basically it scans
out the entire sky so Tess is going to
look at not a hundred percent you can
see we have a few a few open areas near
the equator but about ninety five
percent of this guy will be looking and
watching for exit planets so this movie
shows it much better than I can describe
it
so you can see the moon orbiting the
earth and you can see test goes around
the earth twice for every time the moon
does and in fact the moon I don't know a
lot about orbital mechanics but I do
know that in the process of getting to
that final orbit there's about three
different orbits that it gradually gets
further and further out till it gets
that final orbit and it eases the moon
and gravitational pull from the moon to
hit to get out to that last highly
elliptical orbit so there's a whole lot
of interesting science just to get tests
where it needs to go so now that test is
on its orbit you'll watch and the
outline here that's the field of view of
each of the camera so there's four
cameras in a row and it scans out that's
one months at a time that it's scanning
out now what do you notice about this
part sorry yeah so you this is what we
call the continuous coverage zone right
so in the attempt to see the entire sky
there's going to be some overlap so the
basically at the poles we see almost
full full year coverage now we're going
to the southern hemisphere this is year
or two of the mission same thing we're
going to scan out the entire sky and we
got almost full continuous coverage at
the poles and so not by chance the
follow-on mission has anyone heard of
james webb space telescope yep it's
looking up here so one of Tess's goals
is to provide basically a catalog of
just thousands of places to go look say
go look at the star we think there's an
exit plan there then James Webb doesn't
have to spend a lot of time looking for
them it knows exactly where to go look
and James Webb is going up there to have
the picture it's a little bit further so
James Webb is going up there and is
going to have a target planet and go
look at the atmosphere at that planning
so tests is really just designed to find
planets it can't really characterize
planets James Webb can go up and look at
the atmospherics of the planets in
question and determine is it really like
earth is it hotter is a colder you know
what's the atmosphere
alright so since you guys are going to
be have already ripped apart cameras are
going to be building your own I figured
I'd show you kind of the insides of the
test camera so we identified our two key
pieces now this is a cut of basically a
section view so there's an awful lot of
stuff going on in there but basically
this whole back end section is our
detector this front end section is our
lens and anybody have any guesses that
some of this stuff you can see in the
back behind the detector you may
recognize anything back there because
you're going to see some of this stuff a
little bit later so detectors pretty
much made up you have your ccd right
that's your silicon active area but you
need some electronics behind it too
right so you guys are going to see that
when you build your Raspberry Pi camera
you can see the electronics that run
that actually pull the image in and then
you're going to do your signal
processing for test that's all done on
this back end now I am much more I'm a
physicist by degree but my whole career
has basically been on lens design and
lens test so this is really more my
sweet spot this lens so we can
characterize it a few different ways so
there's seven different lenses so that
tells you there's an awful lot that goes
into this right because we're looking at
a very specific Band and so that drives
how many lenses we need and what
materials they need to be made out of
and we have to match our detector
because if we image light that and then
use a detector that isn't very sensitive
to that particular wavelength of light
you're not going to get a very good
image but there is one thing I wanted to
stress about tests so your phone takes
really nice clear pictures right and you
can take pictures of your friends and
they're nice and clear test is not that
kind of camera so if you think about
what test is trying to do it's trying to
look at a very wide field of view a huge
area right and does anyone know what
typically happens when you have a camera
and you're trying to look at a very wide
field of view with a camera what do you
notice about that kind of the edges of
the picture does anyone ever seen a very
wide field of view image made
I kind of think of a good example an
old-school camera an old-school photo
the image the edges of the image are not
as good as the center okay so if you are
trying to optimize your camera to look
at a very specific spot you can do
really well in one place but the further
you expand your field of view basically
it's hard to keep the entire field of
view in focus and so what test is not
really concerned about taking really
pretty sharp images all it needs to do
is basically we call it a light bucket
it's trying to collect the light from
the stars in a small enough spot that we
can notice that little change in the
light curve so it's kind of a totally
different type of camera it's not a
pretty pictures camera it's a light
collection camera and the other key
thing to think about when you're
designing a camera so what are you
trying to do with it but also where are
you trying to do that right so test is
going to operate we design it on the
ground at a normal temperature for you
and me but there's a lot of adjustments
that have to go into the design to make
sure that when it's up in space and
really cold that it will operate as
intended so there's a lot that goes into
the camera design it's not just what
you're trying to do but where you're
trying to do it and so this is where
test fits into the exoplanet puzzle we
talked a little bit about this before so
and I wanted to put these pictures in
because they look so different right so
this is what Kepler looked like it was
looking at a very specific section of
sky so it was doing something different
it was looking at a very narrow field of
view and very specific planets tests
you've seen we've got four cameras and
our goal is to just go up there and find
planets but not really characterize them
and then James Webb looks totally
different than we do it's got multiple
instruments on the same on the same
spacecraft and it's going up there they
can actually characterize the
atmospheres of the planets so we get one
step closer to finding out if there
really is another earth-like planet up
in space all right so just to kind of
close out so we've talked about a bunch
of different cameras and one thing I
want to stress they're using
many different fields even if you don't
want to be a camera designer just
understanding how they work and how you
know different things affect them can be
useful to you in so many different
fields now right because them even if
you're into something that's not really
super technical you might end up using
cameras right and so I think no matter
what you choose to do it's nice to have
that ability and to really understand
how they function but if you do really
get into it there's an awful lot of
different areas that you could really
focus on and I think make a make a huge
difference in your field so what you can
do with right cameras right now is have
some fun so I hope you guys have a great
day and hope you have a fun building the
cameras and and figuring out if you know
maybe maybe optical engineering or a
detector or signal processing is your
passion so good luck with the rest of
the day